[Applause] When I got
back to the tent, she wasn't there, so I kept looking for her. It's
okay.
Einaya was fine. Did
Milica do something to her? When I woke up, I didn't feel anything out of place anywhere else. That's why, while I was sleeping, Milica was
erotic.  What are you talking about when you want to do something? Why are you saying this to
Milica? Why are you
two talking about Milica?
There were so many things going on,
but I never thought I'd finally give in to her breasts. I would
n't do that. I'd
rather talk to Milica.  I'm talking about getting Milica to give up on me.
First of all, I'm thinking of having Milica live with me until the end of the year.
[Music] Well,
then I want to go on various dates with Milica and do whatever I want for 5
months.
And I don't know what to say, Kasaki-san, are you a hoax
or an idiot? Wait, if you keep going like this, you
won't give up on Milica, and you'll be
unreasonable again and make us worry. I
thought that wouldn't work, Milica.  I
made Mika promise to give up on me if I don't fall in love with her after 5 months of facing her with all my might.
Milica, you,
Milica,
think you can make me fall in love with you,
Hoshizaki-san.  And then, for five months, I did
n't fall in love with Milica-san,
but instead I showed them how much I was in love with them.
[Music] I do
n't know, but I don't know.